lo que quiero realizar en este vídeo es
que obtengamos una idea general o un
mejor entendimiento acerca de lo que son
los oligopolios y nosotros estaremos
hablando durante todo el vídeo acerca de
esto pero también más adelante en vídeos
futuros voy a hablar de lo que son los
oligopolios pero de forma ilegal y bien
aquí oligopolio viene del griego oli que
significa pocos es lo que estoy poniendo
aquí con rosa y por este lado lo que
estoy poniendo con un rosado más claro
lo de paul y viene la palabra griega de
vendedores aunque ya sé que estamos
acostumbrados que por lo regular polis
en términos de polinomio se refiere a
muchos pero en este contexto viene del
griego de paul y lo que se va a
significar técnicamente vendedores y lo
que resulta interesante acerca de los
oligopolios es que algunas ocasiones
estos actúan más como un monopolio si
ellos coordinan o ellos incluso pueden
sentir que son pocos vendedores pero
entre ellos hay competencia ferozmente
sigue siendo oligopolio y lucen más
cercanos a una perfecta competencia pero
también cuando se organizan no coordinan
les voy a dar un ejemplo digamos de que
son pocos competidores y que hay una
corporación que dice bueno nosotros
tenemos casi todo
esto controlado solo somos pocas
corporaciones así que podemos coordinar
y crear algo diferente mientras a
nosotros nos den una cierta cantidad
podremos elevar los precios y
esencialmente maximizar colectivamente
las ganancias de forma económica como
puedes ver ellos estarían obteniendo con
esto un acuerdo y estarían coordinados y
con esto ellos ganan y esto es legal en
casi todas las ciudades del mundo en el
contexto de que muchas compañías lo
permiten permiten hacer que la mayoría
de los países cuenten con esto y se
lleva todo este tipo de proceso como
coordinación entre varios jugadores o
competencias y estos son oligopolios
pero se les llama también colusión o
también se les puede llamar colusión 'no
y ellos tienen un acuerdo formal entre
ellos a lo que llamaremos jugadores por
aquí son los competidores y como te
darás cuenta los encerré en un cuadrito
ya eso lo llamé cartel que es lo más
cercano a un monopolio y digo que son
como un monopolio porque están actuando
todos pero como un solo conjunto y
acerca de monopolio sabemos que open
actúa como esto pues soy experto
a cuestionándome en si esto implicará
algunas formas de coordinación o alguna
forma de fijación de precios para
realizar una restricción cuantitativa
pero la más famosa y tal vez la única de
las más grandes en el mundo es opec que
significa organización de países
exportadores de petróleo y es un grupo
de doce países que colectivamente
controlan cerca del 79 por ciento de las
reservas de petróleo en todo el mundo
entonces todas las reservas en este
momento o en la actualidad que estén en
su terreno o sea que todavía no son
producidas o el petróleo que sabemos que
aún está por debajo del subsuelo sin
sacarse y que no sabemos exactamente
dónde está pero que sabemos que existe
estas zonas reservas y ellos tienen este
79% de petróleo y ellos también
controlan el 44 por ciento del petróleo
producido en el mundo por lo que ese 44
por ciento del petróleo producido viene
directamente del lópez y
predominantemente vienen de países del
medio oriente pero en la actualidad
también incluyen países aunque estén
fuera
medio oriente y ellos tienen un acuerdo
formal donde habían tratado de
restringir cierta producción por lo que
ellos pueden obtener el precio cualquier
precio que ellos quieran obtener por lo
que al menos están intentando no actuar
como un monopolio pues ellos en sí no
controlan todas las reservas del mundo
ellos no controlan toda la producción
tampoco del mundo pero coordinándolo
ellos pueden actuar como un gran jugador
a quien ellos individualmente están
haciendo crecer y para ver en estos
futuros vídeos sabremos que incluso es
bueno actuar colectivamente para ellos
porque sólo de esta manera podría
resultar de una forma legal porque
serían países que están esquina 2 o
están pegados unos con otros y donde
nadie les pueda decir
oye lo que tú estás haciendo es ilegal y
estos están actuando esencialmente fuera
de las leyes pues ellos tienen un futuro
realmente con un enorme incentivo porque
cualquiera de estos 12 países o 12
ciudades pueden romper el acuerdo
secretamente y que dijeran ok yo voy a
restringir me a una cierta cantidad
solamente con el resto de ustedes
pero yo secretamente voy a producir más
de lo pactado para lograr obtener
precios más altos de lo pactado y poder
vender a la gente con mayor producción y
decir muchas gracias a ti te interesa
llegar a un acuerdo formal para lograr
mantener una disciplina en nuestro
cartel pide que lo rompe pero como
supimos este solo fue un ejemplo de un
tipo de coordinación de una colusión que
así se trataba más como de un monopolio
pero en realidad hay muchos pero
realmente muchísimos casos de
oligopolios al menos lo que yo sé que
son realmente competitivos y adivina que
esto que acaba de anotar coca y pepsi
son los más poderosos donde como todos
sabemos de la simple idea de tener agua
con azúcar y una fórmula especial es un
mercado capaz de sólo utilizar estos dos
ingredientes y después vender millones o
tal vez billones con ayuda de una buena
mercadotecnia donde lo que hace es
convencerte de que si tomas esa agua con
azúcar tú serás cool o estarás como los
demás a la moda y ambas empresas
compiten ferozmente entonces este es
actualmente un caso especial de
oligopolio que realmente tiene dos
jugadores 2
jugadores ya esto lo podríamos llamar
duopolio así es un duopolio porque sólo
destacan dos grandes jugadores y podemos
imaginar otro tipo de duopolio por
ejemplo con estas aerolíneas aeroméxico
y magnicharters puesto que si tú quieres
viajar o bueno volar en este caso son
estas dos las más destacadas en especial
cuando hablas de una aeronave comercial
entonces tendremos estas dos opciones
aeroméxico aeronaves y magnicharters
aeronaves donde aeroméxico está hecha
por mexicanos y magnicharters está hecha
por americanos y siempre tienen la
disputa dice aeroméxico que siempre todo
el apoyo de americanos lo recibe de
magnicharters y magnicharters siempre
está en queja de que méxico recibe digo
que aeroméxico recibe todo el apoyo de
mexicanos y esto es evidente y ellos
siempre están en una competencia feroz
con los precios de ambos negociándose de
los países con aerolíneas que están en
busca de comprar nuevos aviones o
cualquier cosa que necesiten y algo
parecido de oligopolios sucede así como
con lópez tenemos también las aerolíneas
este es un juego de varias aerolíneas
porque tenemos que las aerolíneas lucen
como un juego
de competencia perfecta es un claro
ejemplo en la industria de perfecta
competencia puesto que tenemos
demasiados competidores y todos ellos
están conscientes el uno del otro y
ellos saben que los precios de otros a
algunos les banadesa cordaro van a estar
incomodando les pero están en búsqueda
constante de otros precios para que
ellos mismos puedan estar bien con los
suyos así que como puedes ver las
aerolíneas no serían un duopolio aquí
voy a dibujar una línea que nos lo
divide apuesto que sería un claro
ejemplo de oligopolio que es donde el
mercado aprovecha la competencia
perfecta y aquí tenemos otro claro
ejemplo que sería con visas que pudieras
tener no sé mastercard o american expres
y realmente estas dos primeras dominan
en este tipo de mercado por lo que una
vez en este ejemplo tenemos otra vez
varios jugadores y ellos no están
coordinados meramente como tú sabes que
es algo lejano que ellos puedan
coordinarse por lo que están
constantemente compitiendo pero ellos
han estado en casos en compañías
especialmente en oligopolios y todo
repentinamente hacen una búsqueda de una
especie de tipo de acuerdo a trastienda
donde
ellos dicen que les gustaría cooperar
juntos para que no levanten su
producción y puedan juntos guardar
ciertos precios altos para que ambos
tengan una especie de titular de la
disciplina y es aquí donde los gobiernos
se ven envueltos en regular y hacer
seguro esto para que no se salga de
control hacer un seguro donde ambas
partes o ellos realmente nada en este
tipo de cosas de coordinación es porque
casi todos los gobiernos tienen un punto
de vista de que les gustaría llevar una
competencia perfecta o lo más cercano la
competencia perfecta para que tuviera
una buena economía pues entre más lejos
se encuentren de obtener un monopolio la
economía se estabilizará o encontrará
mejores oportunidades para extenderse